I'm going to go ahead and put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to put it back in the oven and
I'm going to put it back in the oven and I'm going to add the
Jamie's
Oh, you're finally here.
What took you so long?
I ordered my food an hour ago
and you only just got here.
I think that's poor service.
I think you owe me now.
I get a lot of evidence right inside.
I'm scared.
I'm scared about it.
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Sorry, am I too close?
You've still got lost.
I don't think my house is that hard to find, really.
I think it's quite easy to find where I am.
I apologize if you hear scratching in the background.
That's the last person who I ordered from.
They're scrabbling around the house right now.
I don't have any cats.
It's just rats.
Does the rain sound okay?
I hope it does.
The rain is rather loud.
Oh, you're soaked.
That's a pity.
You know, I have some towels if you need to dry off.
It's no issue, really.
Oh, I can always heat up the food.
It's no problem.
Not a problem at all.
Where do you think you're going?
You can't leave?
Why are you trying the door?
You really should just hang out.
It's locked.
I think, you know, the best way to repay me is, you know,
accept my hospitality for a while and come in and dry off.
You have other orders?
Oh, that's fine.
Your other deliveries can wait like I did.
There's no use trying to leave.
Here, take a seat.
Sit with me on the couch.
Put your button.
Grab you a towel.
Here you go.
I know it looks similar to a blanket, but I swear it's a very nice towel.
So why don't you just put that?
Yeah, just wipe yourself off, okay?
You think the towel smells nice?
That's good. I just used it.
Shocked I live alone out here.
Oh, it's no issue.
No issue at all.
I quite like the solitude.
Yes, sometimes I get sad I don't have anyone to share it with.
You can't leave my hat.
I have to make sure I like the food or I give you your review.
Maybe you can redeem yourself by behaving and I won't give you one star.
Stop arguing with me.
Sorry, I didn't mean to use that tone of voice.
You can continue trying.
Do you need help?
I can help you.
I don't think I need help here.
It's so wet and soaking.
We must have been standing outside in the rain for quite some time.
Doing so many different deliveries.
Besides mine.
Okay, here I go.
I try not to hold grudges.
There's some holding grudges.
I hope I am quite a nice lady.
There's no need for you to worry.
No need at all.
What's that?
Let me take care of you.
What can I do?
You took so long on my damn order.
I got the fight.
I want all the grudge.
Put on me if you stay put and believe.
I get so lonely here sometimes.
So lonely.
There you go.
We aren't right off now.
Do you feel a little bit better?
You can come sit with me on the couch.
Why don't you like that?
I think you would.
Why don't you?
Of course.
You can sit right next to me if you want.
You won't get the couch wet.
You do that all the time.
It's no problem.
So I see that my food is still in your hand.
Do you mind if I...
Can you pass it to me please?
Thank you.
You didn't take any bites, did you?
I've had people do that before.
I'm just going to inspect everything if you don't mind.
I know there's ways to replace the sticker.
Uh-uh.
Where do you think you're going?
Come back here.
Come on.
Come back down.
I'm not done looking through the food yet.
Good boy.
So obedient.
Add a little feisty.
I think everything is in order.
Have some silverware.
I have a food here.
It seems like something is missing.
I specifically ordered a drink.
I don't see it here.
I ordered a diet doctor kelp.
I definitely ordered a drink.
Where is it?
Did you take it?
No.
It says it there in my order.
I'll show you on my phone.
Just scroll down.
It's right there.
What do you have to say for yourself?
Did you drink my diet doctor kelp?
Be honest.
I promise I won't get too mad.
Or hurt you.
I don't know why I keep saying such silly things.
Oh, wait.
Hi.
I found it here.
It was on the floor.
Were you trying to hide it?
I'll keep it for yourself.
It seemed to have rolled under my couch.
Pretty odd, I do say.
Moa, you couldn't just be honest with me?
Let's get it open.
I hope it's not shaken up.
Do you mind?
It doesn't seem to be working.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Oh, very sweet.
It's with the soda.
Open, Moa.
Don't mind if I do.
No, I don't need any ice.
I love how it sizzles on my tongue.
Did you want a sip?
I don't mind.
You seem like a good boy that doesn't have any serious diseases or anything.
But you do seem like a dirty boy.
Sorry.
Here, you can have a sip.
I don't mind one bit.
Sometimes that happens.
Here.
Why don't you have a sip?
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to burp in your face.
Here, pass it back to me.
Are you good, huh?
Usually I don't make these sugary drinks.
What's that on your dot mind?
Would you like to share my food?
I need to try it.
I would like if you stuck around.
I hope I'm getting too close to some bothering.
Here, there's even an extra fork.
You work so hard.
It's only fair that I share my meal with you.
Even though you don't deserve it and you took forever.
I don't know.
He's such fancy things to transport for holidays.
Uh-oh.
It seems that I dropped a book.
You might go down to get it.
Please.
You're burping, huh?
I think it's right there.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
You can just share a fork instead.
I promise I don't have any goodies.
It tastes pretty good.
You're a good kid.
That's so sweet.
Five of all of us.
Do you want me to feed you?
Like a good boy?
No, I bet you could do it yourself.
Right?
I don't mind though.
If you want me to, you just have to open your mouth.
I'll give you what you want.
A delicious bite.
Say hi.
Uh-huh.
Now a part of me is inside you.
You're so easily fooled.
Here, you can actually have a bite.
Yeah, open wide just like that.
Good little delivery driver you are.
Okay, chew.
Go on.
Now swallow.
Good job.
You're so good at following directions.
I like it when you gulp it down like that.
Good night.
I keep eating right now.
I actually think I quite like where I am sitting in front of you.
So I think I'll stay here and continue eating.
This is very, very good.
I have to then see the chew too loudly sometimes.
I hope you don't mind how loud I can chew.
There's a drink.
I like how it feels as it runs down the back of my throat gulping down.
That's some good diet doctor help will tell you that much.
Do you want any more food?
No.
You look delicious enough to eat yourself.
I wonder what if I just...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
This side would be tastier.
Perhaps maybe.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Uh oh.
I think I have to poop again.
I can eat some dvds.
I wonder what your mouth tastes like.
Not as good as your ears are, but it's fine.
You know, you're kind of cute.
You could stay over if you wanted.
I'm up to you.
Well, you probably have other deliveries or whatever.
It doesn't matter to me.
If not, I would still like to try some things with you as a recompense for you bringing my food light.
Hmm.
Oh, it's not too much of a problem.
I won't upset your schedule.
Are you sure?
Are you positive?
I would hate to be a burden for you.
I hope you don't pick up me as too much trouble.
Oh, thank you so much.
You're so sweet, thank kind to me.
Just a little customer.
I don't think I deserve you.
Such a good boy.
So, why don't you come home and couch with me?
And I'll take care of you, and then I'll send you on your merry way.
Yes, come on.
I think this will be easier if I sat in your lap.
I want you to try this massaging technique.
I hope you don't mind if I try it on you.
And that's it. I swear I won't let you go.
Whoops, you have other requests of me that you would want me to do to you.
Hmm.
Okay.
Thank you.
Does that feel all right?
Boy.
What a good delivery boy you are.
How are you working this kind of job anyway?
You seem like you should be doing something more.
Excited.
You need the money?
You know, if you were mine, I would take really good care of you.
You wouldn't have to worry about money ever again.
Perfect, you'll be my little pet.
Perfect.
You're so soft and attached.
Your skin is like silk.
You're so fine. You have a lot of jokes, don't you?
I like a pet that can make me laugh.
The last one doesn't make me laugh.
They make me angry.
Are you gonna make me angry?
Why would you please me like a good boy?
Good.
Very good.
All right.
Well, you did a favor for me.
You spent time with me while I was alone.
So, what can I do to make you happy?
I think you like the massage and the tapping.
So, I'll take some special requests from you.
What can I do to help?
Use any inks and paint.
You know, I have a very special method to make a lot of paint go away.
Do you wanna know what it is?
It's very simple.
So, let me just get behind you.
And I have this thing where I say a few words while counting backwards from them.
So, the paint will go away.
Do you think you can handle that?
Do you promise?
Okay, let's try it.
Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
Zapp!
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1
9, 7, 8, 9, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 21, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 35, 36, 38, 40, 39, 41, 41
no no no no no no no no no setting
I thought I was going to count to zero, but do you feel more relaxed now?
I want to scratch your brain.
Scroll inside it.
Stretch a little.
You can even pull my nose.
Sorry, don't mind that.
Okay, is there anything you want me to do?
I think you're more quiet.
Just a little bit.
One second.
I think these pop rocks are nice.
These ones are good.
You should not have peckled.
Just a little bit.
Let's see.
What other triggers would you guys like?
Snapping.
I can do snapping and sniffing and affirmations.
Sorry, that's a kid outside.
I thought that was a cat.
Yeah, it wasn't a cat. That was a child.
Outside my window.
Which is crazy because I'm on my fourth one.
What's up my line of work?
Oh, I'm what they call a woman of the night.
Oh, what do you want?
What do you want?
Sorry, there's a camera on my keyboard.
Does he know?
I don't think he knows.
Make sure to check all my links in the description below.
I think it's time I give you a sniff.
Let's see if you smell good enough to eat again.
Smell stinky.
A rabbit is sniffing you and she says you smell stinky.
That's a good stink.
Smell stinky.
Hold on, neighbor is walking by.
Okay, I think they're gone. Quite noisy.
You guys have positive affirmations.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, it's delicious.
I'm gonna blow my nose again.
I can't get this to you.
It's a bee.
Hi.
I hope you had a good day today.
You're so sweet. You deserve the bestest updates.
I wish I could give you anything you ever wanted.
You work so hard. I just want to give back to you.
You do such a good job for yourself. I know it might be hard every day.
But you want to make sure you count the little victories. That's what I always say.
Even if your little victory today was just getting out of bed this morning, I want you to be proud of yourself.
If you brushed your teeth, I want you to be proud.
If you took a shower, if you changed your clothes, you made your bed.
If you made an effort today, if you just tried your best.
That's all that matters.
I'm really proud of you. You may think that you're not good enough, but you are.
You're too good. Such a good boy.
Such a good boy.
Especially for mommy.
You do such great things. You need to give yourself a little bit more credit.
Sorry, that's my chair.
I want to give you a hug sometimes when you're sad, because I know you've had a rough day in the past.
Just know everything's gonna be okay.
I'll be here by your side, even when you have nobody else. Don't forget that.
I'm giving you the biggest hugs.
You're the softest, sweetest kisses.
I love you very much.
I'm so grateful and thankful for you every day, but you can't rely on me for your happiness.
You've got to look in words at yourself and remind yourself how great of a person you are,
because you're a good person. You try your hardest.
And you deserve everything for that.
I want you to try to be the best person you can be. Yes, a better person.
But you'll be difficult, because you're already perfect, but it doesn't hurt to try.
I want you to treat yourself with kindness.
I want you to treat everybody else around you with kindness.
Oh.
That was crazy.
Come on, that's a 10.
I think you guys like, so I do really loud burps. I think you guys just like longer burps.
I wish I could grow up with you and lay on your chest.
Yeah, you guys prefer length.
Size doesn't matter. Length doesn't matter to me. I like them short and sweet.
There's nothing wrong with short and sweet, because they still pack a pretty big punch.
I got them girthy burps.
What do you mean that ain't a compliment?
I'm not even, you know what?
I try to be nice, because I'm telling the truth, but nobody cares.
Whatever. Whatever.
You guys don't like me because I'm small. Fine.
You guys don't like my small burps? Fine.
Hi. Can I appreciate a small burp?
And a large burp?
Okay.
I especially love these stinky burps.
My Joker moment. I've had my Joker moment a long time ago.
What do you mean? Oh, I'm talking about burps.
Um, oh, let me continue. You are a lovely human being.
Never forget that. I want you to try your hardest.
I want you to stop putting off that thing that you keep putting off and I want you to get to it and get it done.
Because I know you'll feel so much better when you do.
That thing that's been weighing in the back of your mind.
I want you to experience that sense of relief when you finally get it done.
And that sense of achievement when you complete something.
Human being. You're my little mean. I'll flick you around.
Do your homework. Get that project done.
Send that text message. Make that phone call.
Clean up your resume. Go to that interview. Send that email.
Have a good night.
Move that house. Pack up those boxes.
Get right to it. I'll be cross with you if you don't finish the project.
Kiss my seabee.
Make sure you get that stuff done. You know?
And then you can do all the fun stuff like hanging out with me or the other girls.
And watching our streams and spending time with us.
Okay? You got to do it.
A good boy so listen to me.
A good boy so listen to mommy.
Okay? Good.
You guys are so good to me. I'm so appreciative of you.
I don't know what I would do without you to be honest.
Thank you for always keeping me company.
Listening to me.
And not just listening to me telling you what to do when you're actually having a conversation in my streams.
I hope you guys like the new audio. That's the one I recorded last month so I hope I have some improvement.
October audios will be better because now I have fixed my microphone so it's not going to sound as bad.
Can you even use it? I don't know what you mean.
You fell asleep to it. Oh, you're nice.
Good. Very good.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What day is it today?
Oh, Friday was yesterday.
Today or next Friday?
Hmm. Curious. Very curious.
Okay.
Are there some other triggers you guys wanted?
Hmm?
As you wish. Oh, for my birthday week, we're going to watch The Princess Bride, my favorite movie.
I think I might finish. But then I'll wait for you guys next Friday to finish.
I think that's fair.
Princess Bride is my favorite movie of all time.
Good girl. That's a good girl. Good girl.
My two good girl watchers.
You've never seen The Princess Bride. My God. What's wrong with you?
I'm so sleepy.
I wish I could take you guys to the couch with me and I could fall asleep like we did on the space.
Oh, by the way, the end of the roleplay. I kill you and I eat you, by the way.
Spoiler alert.
Yeah. I'm like a spider. I eat.
So warm.
It's been so nice spending time with you, but I think it's time you leave now and end up in my tummy.
Oh, you want to get beaten? I can tend. I don't really know how to do that.
I almost popped the microphone. Oh, wait, I know.
That just sounds like I'm beating it off.
Punch the mic. Punch the mic. Punch the mic. Punch the mic.
You were the order. That's correct, actually.
I like to play with my food before I eat it.
Grab my hands.
But I'm holding the 3DO, so I'm just going to smack my teeth in.
Whoa.
Punch.
Okay, I don't think I'm going to do that.
That was really loud.
Blackflake power. Okay, time to eat you.
Oh.
Oh, no. Wait, I need to be closer.
Oh, my freckles.
I can't get any closer than this.
One of five.
Ooh.
Oh.
This will give me a strike.
You're being bored.
Oh, my head's cut off. Don't worry about it.
Oh.
Oh, my head's cut off.
I can also purr like a cat.
If you're going to name these triggers, you can do sheebie purr and then sheebie parry.
Yippee. Please YouTube, I'm not sucking pee pee. I'm just trying to move my model, I swear.
Oh, my head's cut off.
Oh, please hold.
I'm so sleepy.
Oh, I'm so tired.
I am but a young innocent girl, and I'm so innocent.
I'm not dressed a certain way asking for something.
No, not at all.
If you don't do it, I'll scurry you.
I mean what?
Oh, wait, what's that trigger that Para actually told me?
That makes my tongue feel weird.
You guys like that sound?
That's actually me licking my top lip really fast.
It's making me drool.
It's good.
Imagine, you can see my mouth will be like...
My tongue tracking isn't fast enough.
I need a burp.
Every time I have seltzer water, it makes me burp. I mean die, Dr. Kelp.
You like me even though I'm disgusting?
Please? You love me? How much do you love me?
Tell me now, tell me now, tell me now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This much? You love me 1000? More than any, that's cool.
You're lying. You're lying.
You want me?
I think you're dealing me.
It's just time to be soon, someday.
I am unbothered, soon the recipe.
Like a wifey, think I'm wifey.
You think I'm wifey?
I'm blushing? No.
No? I'm not blushing?
I'm not doing anything.
No?
Wait for a poetic, I have to plan it.
I won't be for it.
I mean we're still, you know, we're still, we're still dating.
I don't want to rush things.
I don't know about juice and things.
You know what you don't know about me?
We just need to grow together.
There's a couple.
My puppy is itchy.
Actually I don't.
You guys know way more about me than I do when you talk about me.
Tell me something about yourself.
That you're having cold.
Or like you're usually scared to tell other people.
Do it right now and chat with everybody watching.
But you know.
Welcome to Hyrule member.
Welcome.
Your position, really? That's cool.
I can tie my own hands up. That's pretty neat.
I like long walks on the beach and sometimes I have severe depression about what it's been a while.
I feel that, bro. I feel that.
If someone who has long-term dyspnea.
Hope to see that.
That's a given. You're neat.
You have had a cold? Yeah.
Very cool.
Your eyes are so pretty.
You have a beautiful, ony girlfriend.
What is ony?
Bro, please tell the story.
I used to play in a band. What kind of band?
I have 116 levels of room craft.
I've never played a room escape, guys.
I love things in my back.
I like how you said that.
You're afraid of flamingos. Why?
My job might kill me eventually because I work with low level radiation.
That's intense. You do intense work. That's impressive.
I'm Mexican? Sorry.
I can think of anything secret that's positive.
Or you can just, you don't have to say a secret.
You can just say what you like to do.
A little medical ward? That's cool.
I start every year standing in the Atlantic Ocean at midnight for new years.
That's super neat.
I've done a polar plunge a couple of times.
I get hit by old people daily at my job as someone who used to work in human services.
I feel that.
I am a Floridian. Get out of here.
I collect arcade sticks. That's pretty cool.
I learned English because of games and shows. That's pretty neat.
A lot of people usually learn it from TV.
I get good benefits. That's what you do.
I invented a Mexican quantum computer.
What the fuck? Einstein's in my chat right now. Holy shit.
Good on you, bro. Thank you for the work you do.
I could keep working, but I nearly broke my ankle last week.
Oh, no.
I live in Italy.
Oh, Italia.
Buongiorno.
And bambino pizza.
Sorry. I number 35 digits of pie.
I can say the alphabet backwards in two seconds.
I'm way smarter than me.
I live in Illinois, and I have mental Illinois.
I'm Mexican. I speak Spanish. I feel nude.
Hey, man. I'm a Haitian. I can't speak Creole, so I feel that.
I hold long conversations. I imagine people in my head saying,
They like my fancy house. Hi, Miwa.
Everyone say hi, Miwa.
My wabby sister from another mista.
I'm so lame compared to these.
I have a bachelor's degree, but I haven't found a job.
That's a bummer.
I'm a federal agent who investigates male fraud.
You know, it's really interesting learning a guy's jobs,
because I'm just like,
What has drawn you to anime girls on the internet?
I got sponsored projects for a metal 3D printer for senior design.
Can you get the gritty note?
It's one of the most interesting things that I have in Fantasia.
I think we talked about this last time.
Are you the one with a Fantasia?
Or is there somebody else with a Fantasia?
I think it was somebody else with a Fantasia.
There's a second person with a Fantasia in here.
What's the ATF?
I'm quite a moan and can't speak.
They're hot? True.
Oh, you know what?
Tell me how you guys got into VTubers.
Tell me, how did you get into VTubers?
You want to know how I got into VTubers?
I used to be into VTubers when they first came to existence.
But the one time I decided I wanted to be a VTuber,
was when I actually watched Anthony Padilla's video
interviewing Iron Mouse and some other VTubers.
And it actually made me want to try to be a VTuber.
But I watched them.
But that's how I decided I wanted to be one.
How Alive? Yeah?
How did you get into How Alive? How did you find out?
COVID?
Oh, I won the COVID babies.
COVID VTuber babies.
Okay.
Kitsune AI?
Kizuna?
Do I have an Oshi?
My Oshi is graduating tomorrow.
My comedy Oshi.
Sand.
Everybody knows my Oshi is chilly.
I'm very sad.
But she is going to do great things.
She's such a wonderful person.
She's really talented.
She graduates the eighth.
Pillow Deer?
I just got in the Pillow Deer.
She's really good.
I want to take her ASMR 101 class.
Nene Amano Senju Linga.
Pikami!
Pikami, sweet.
Very cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a bummer.
But I hope, you know,
I want her to do what she loves
and what makes her happy.
She's very light.
How do you know she's your first VTuber?
Oh, nice.
I must speak with the other girls.
I'm a standard normal office worker.
How does it feel being in comedy?
Baking in comedy? I haven't baked a comedy Oshi.
When somebody said that I was a comedy Oshi,
oh my god, I'm going to cry thinking of it.
Especially some of my friends,
like Mari and Poman, told me I'm a comedy Oshi
and I literally wanted to cry
because I feel like I'm not good enough for that.
Honor.
So, yeah.
It's very crazy.
I can't see past my tears.
I want my eyes.
Of course you are good.
Thank you, Miwa.
Thank you.
I'm trying my best out here.
Just like I hope you guys are.
I just want to make everybody happy.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you guys for deciding that I'm good enough
to support or really be your first, et cetera.
I'm not the impressive VTubing.
I have a lot to learn.
I discovered that actually out of Vilaire,
I'm the one with the least experience
writing a VTuber.
Everybody else has been doing it much longer than I have been.
They have a couple of years on me.
Although I know Strani hasn't been a VTuber for long either,
but she has a lot more content creation under her belt than me.
So I kind of feel like a baby in Vilaire for that reason.
It's kind of funny.
Thank you guys.
VTubers.
Well, just the VTubers.
I think they've all streamed longer than me too, actually.
Okay.
Yeah, Mumay believed in me.
She saw herself in me, which is a major honor.
So she's grooming me to be her.
To try to be entertaining.
I feel like I'm getting better.
I want to be great.
I want to be up there with the greats.
I want to have a good influence.
I'm kind of bummed because sometimes my big mouth gets me in trouble.
And I say things that, again, I can be really blunt.
And I know that can turn people away,
but I'm just going to try to keep going and keep my head down.
And, you know, speak my mind in a more tactful way.
I've got a word choice.
Nope, she's grooming me.
I might be on my ears.
I'm a baby.
I'm a baby at the age of 56, turning 57, September 28.
Yeah, but I've already mentioned before,
my big mouth gets Vilaire in trouble.
Well, not in trouble, just like,
I don't want to reflect badly on them.
No, that'll still be open with you.
What are you talking about?
I'm not going to stop being open.
Yeah, refined communication skills.
I still have to remember I'm someone with a platform, you know?
And, you know, what I say.
I was talking with my parents about it today.
They're like, oh, what's been going on?
And I'm like, well, I have my period and I want to die.
Two, I might have made a couple mistakes
because I realized I don't know how to carry myself properly on the internet.
And sometimes you have to learn the hard way.
Yeah, I can answer my own string at some point.
So, what did my dad say?
I forget, he said something very wise in the old that you never get.
But yeah, I never stopped learning my mouth's a feature.
Oh, yeah.
You like my little hawk-tua?
If she don't hawk-tua, I don't talk to a hawk-tua.
Yeah, just like, pretty much, I was just like, ah, brainwaves.
I feel like I'm just kind of letting everybody down with my based opinions.
And my dad's like, you take too much, you put too much stock
and what other people say and think about you, you really got to take care of yourself.
And I'm like, bet, father, bet!
He said it more wisely than that, but you know.
Hawk-tua!
Why can't I say hawk-tua?
I hate your brainworms.
Gonna record, yeah.
I just need to find out.
I'm guys, I'm so busy preparing stuff.
Oh my god, I almost dropped the ASMR mic.
Okay, wait, I'm so busy preparing.
And I haven't been feeling good.
Shark Week is kicking me in my coochie.
My dad is awesome and so is my mom.
My mom is like, because my mom used to work in a very corporate environment
and she's just like, you know, you just go, you're about yourself.
And my mom is like, you know, people will always have this idea of you
and you can try to change their minds.
But in the end, it's like people are gonna think of how they want to think
and you can't get worked up and upset over something you can't control.
Because again, I have a thing with control.
And my mama, um, my mama, it's funny.
I used to, when I was younger, I used to, because I just wanted to be a British child, apparently.
My mom said, I used to always call her mumsie.
I mean, I don't have mumsie.
And every time she picked me up from my after school program.
Yeah, my parents keep my hand on my shoulders a hundred percent.
I speak Spanish.
No, no habla espaol.
And, um,
muy,
en familia,
en espaol,
en perdido.
Good.
Oh, no, man.
My Spanish gets mixed up, too, with my friends.
You're gonna take me for free?
Hey, do you want to go and dozing?
What was that?
Thank you.
Was that a didgeridoo?
Does that sound like I'm going to go and dozing?
That's me just pressing on my voice box.
That sounds bad.
I probably shouldn't do that.
My voice is cracking now.
Yard work day is somewhere in win.
He's not ready to do a thing.
Squidward, that's a read.
Don't get your throat off.
That's the language of the tree.
I'm tired.
It sounds like somebody's even possessed.
Okay, sorry.
Nightmare, nightmare, nightmare.
I have a crazy voice range.
Can you believe that?
I just laughed like a monkey.
Nightmare, nightmare, nightmare.
Sound of a teenager at the do-all-work.
She wonders why people are gone, because I make monkey noises.
ooh o-ooh o-okay
ooh o-ok
wow
y5 no
okay
I was making oop oop oop oop O goths
s really impressed
SHABURAEO
Or, or, ultimately.
Wait, I didn't think that somebody, somebody,
Right here! It's like, Sheavey should start worrying about being white!
Nothing!
No, Sheave.
No!
Mo!
I'm making...
Shoad?
It sounds like chode!
I'm making voices!
You know, people ask me, Sheavey,
Does it hurt to maintain this voice when you go this high?
It actually doesn't. It's actually quite easy for me to do.
And then...
There should be an interview chat, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat!
I don't know why it's on Eastern European.
RIP SLEEPER!
I think I got off from policy. I never watched that!
And then, you know, I had a little bit of rasp to it,
And then, you know, you got your little smug piece of shit!
I just got really high.
I mean, oh, it's because my AC is off.
So that makes sense.
I sound like Pipa!
No, I don't think so.
If you're hot, cool off, I just dump my seltzer water on me.
Although, I will say, I very much identify with Pipa's tan version.
I'm like, me.
Her little tan outfit.
I think it's cute with those little tan lines.
I'm like, oh, it's like Pipa!
Pipa, no!
No.
It's just tan.
She'd be in Pipa collab when double buttons.
She would never collab with me, guys.
I don't think anyone from FaZe would ever collab with us.
I used to have a baby when I saw them.
If you could see one of the girls collab with someone from FaZe, who would it be?
Like, who would you pair Emmy up with?
Or IC?
You don't know about that?
You're right, I don't. That's true.
I see you're seeing it.
Emmy would be the first.
Emmy gets along with everyone.
I kind of agree with you that they won't collab with you.
Thank you.
You know, I forgot to put the chat up for LaVaude.
I'm sorry, LaVaude Watchers.
David and Colin.
Perfect voice for Clonny Sheenby.
You guys want Clonny Sheenby so bad.
Who would you want to make?
I don't even know, like, if I were to get a model, who would I have to do the model?
You know?
You and Pippa have a similar sense of humor.
Yeah, we do.
I think, like, Romeo and Juliet, our fan bases would want to keep us apart.
I feel like that goes for a lot of people.
I know there's, like, some people that you guys don't want us to, like, associate with.
I've had people in my marriage be like, you responded to this person's tweet.
Please be careful.
And I'm like, I just responded like the tweet.
I'd like to see you collab with Doki.
Doki, you know?
I want to have Doki teach me how to do a pep.
You think Waifu Baby's designer would make that Clonny Sheenby?
No, no, no.
If I...
Me and Shiori.
I can't.
God girls with runny mascara.
Shondo?
Tell me.
I like Shondo.
She'd be at Shiori and Shiori could probably up about books for hours.
I love me some running mascara.
Oh yeah, no, I died.
I died.
I don't have 3D debut.
I was like, oh.
I could tell you more.
No, I couldn't.
If I were to get a cute and funny model, what model artist would you guys recommend?
Hypothetically?
No?
So good.
I do love so good.
They open their...
What you might call it soon, actually?
I am the Brat and the Brats theme.
I mean, what has it probably been?
Oh, I wear this look before for my rental model.
They were absolutely so sweet and kind.
And they made exactly what I wanted.
I would definitely work with Valkyrie again.
I don't know if Brie would rig for us.
It's very difficult to find an artist in rigor.
That's okay with the nature of the side content we do in terms of our patriarchal ideas.
I wouldn't want to make anybody comfortable if I end up using a model.
And I don't like the content I'm associated with.
I don't know if that person is one of them.
But I just want to make sure everyone is comfortable.
Yeah.
I have a headache.
That's another reason why I kind of don't reach out for collapse anymore.
I now just ask permission if people are allowed to hang out with us because of the nature of our side content.
And I'd rather be like, hey, you want to collab and do this, this, and that.
And they're like, no.
And I'm just like, hey, you have firms to hang out with us.
It's like they can't even make.
And they're just like, yes.
Or they're like, no.
And I'm like, okay.
That's why I hang out with a lot of indies.
But I'm okay with that.
I want people to be comfortable.
I don't want to make anybody uncomfortable.
Oh, it's because of my.
Because my ASMR microphone is on my phone number.
Model my signal from me.
Yeah.
That's for permission.
Like melody.
No.
Okay.
That's why you can collaborate.
Well, they're just like, like, yeah, some people also, you know, will sometimes view collapse as a business relationship.
And because we're smaller, some people wouldn't want to collab with us.
Me, I like to view stuff as just like, hey, I think your content is me and you seem like a cool person.
Do you want to hang out?
I don't care how big or small you are, but I got it.
Oh, I took the risk of colliding with them.
I think AI too.
Dream collaboration.
That would be cool.
Yeah.
Same purpose.
Well, it'll probably still happen.
But guys, guys, guys, anytime.
It's not, no, no, no, no, it's not judgmental.
It's not judgmental.
It's not, no, no, no.
It's not the people.
It's just like, for example, like, like some stuff in other countries, they can't do this, this or that.
Like it's branding.
It's just business.
It's nothing personal.
Nobody, yeah, preconceived notions.
And, you know, yeah, there might be a little bit of that.
But, well, you know.
But I think people kind of now have a general idea because now more of the time I see more people disappointed that we don't do certain things than us doing certain things.
Um, generally, someone's like, what?
They're not, you know, on the cat website?
Were they, you know, bait those cats?
Um, and we're like, no, let me just audio.
No, no.
Yeah, exactly.
It's all branding stuff, guys.
Nothing personal.
Yeah, I'm saying myself, um, I'm actually, I think, because I reached out to a company, like a big girl, and I asked like questions and it had them explain stuff to me.
So another company was kind enough to explain stuff to me as to like why certain companies may not be able to collaborate.
And that made me feel a lot better their transparency.
Um, so now I actually don't feel bad about it anymore because I'm just like, people hate us!
Wow!
But they don't.
They don't hate us.
Yes, you know, it's just a lot of stuff, business stuff.
So now I just do my own thing, you know, with my girly pops.
Also, keep in mind, we have like, more petite body types in our company, and some people don't like that either, so.
I, you know, respectful.
There's no ill will, nobody hates us.
It's fine.
We're just hanging out.
We're just, we're carving a path, exactly.
Who knows, maybe next year, there'll be another company just like us, and maybe it'll be more normalized.
And maybe we'll hang out with those people.
I'm using the word petite.
If you look right, no, it's fine.
Guys, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Although, Estonia's told me there has been some like, big names interested in us, and she's like, very honest.
And they would be pretenders to the throne.
I need to turn on the light.
I like how this turned into a zatsu.
I'm so sorry.
I swear, I talk too much.
I'm sorry.
Boom.
Okay.
I need to turn on the AC.
Moomi is so fat.
Your voice is pretty talk more.
No, you, Miwa.
Miwa.
Miwa, are we gonna hang out, actually?
I should probably.
I was like, thinking about that today.
I saw you post on Twitter.
Oh yeah, Miwa has a new ASMR video out.
Please go check out her channel on YouTube.
She has a wonderful ASMR.
Please check her out.
And I was, so I saw that post.
I'm like, you know, I should probably like, actually make a collab with Miwa.
Besides just like an ASMR.
Like we should probably actually hang out.
I didn't get, no.
I'm just going to give memberships.
Hey, Goober.
Um, I don't know if you'll have an actual AB to Bacopo's competitors or friendly rivals.
Yeah, that's a great question.
Um, I would hope to be friends with another English.
We're not even really, we're not really an AB to Bacopo anymore.
Because we just do well.
Yes.
Do the House of Blue Streams count?
No.
I don't know.
Anyways, um.
Alright.
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
Oh Miwa!
Miwa got hit with a gift.
Thank you, John, on me.
Got her.
Sniped.
And thank you.
Whoever found them.
Thank you for the gift.
I appreciate it.
Stop!
Stop it!
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you for the gift and no one's special.
And Miwa, thank you for the five gifts.
The guys are too nice.
Oops, thank you.
It was Miwa's plan all along.
I obey women.
Hello, I'm right here.
I am also a woman.
Excuse me.
Yeah, I guess the cunny.
The cunny really just rules.
Yeah, it's funny.
It was fun.
Thank you.
I am right here.
It's funny.
Imagine if I got like a cute and funny model
and then I just like talking to my mommy voice all the time
and just be like, hey guys,
what are you doing?
Are you behaving?
And then I just like,
but I'm like just like so small.
I made it.
Hi there.
Where you been?
Kiddo?
I won gay harlot.
I mean, gay harlot.
Just do impressions of your dad.
I was gonna have my parents pilot my model again,
but my mom was like so hyper focused on this new Netflix show
called Outlast.
And I'm like the video game and my dad's like, no,
and it's about people in Alaska.
No.
No, Karen.
Thank you for your safety gifted.
What?
Alice is a good girl.
You didn't have to do that.
You guys are too kind today.
Save your money.
My food.
Pay your bills.
Strawny uses like, okay.
So how much do you want to put for your stretch goals
for your birthday?
Don't have fun.
I'm like, okay, so first stretch goal for 5000
and she's like, what?
I'm like, last time,
you know, like I can put it out like 1000
and she's just like,
she be.
And I'm like, I don't want anything.
She's like, she be.
You need to be able to get a new computer in 3D
and I'm like, okay.
Yeah.
Go back to save your money for the stone.
Get money to buy a house.
That would be cool.
Oh, hey, look, you got hit with one bro.
Good for you.
Now use emote.
Hey, do maternal part two.
That's a great question.
I have to play that and hit man.
They're both just like unlisted on my channel.
I did not put them on the rest of my schedule
for the month.
I just realized that cause I already set up
my schedule for the month.
Trackically didn't even do a part one.
The noodle module for dude.
Have you figured?
Oh yeah.
No, I'm, I know what I'm doing for the birthday stream.
Me and Strani are cooking.
Mostly Strani.
Strani's like, I got this.
I'm like, okay.
The stream was cursed.
It was perfect.
Um, I, yeah, it's two 12 hour days.
The 28th is my birthday
and then the 29th is the day after.
Yeah.
Has to great what?
First thing.
The stream will come down and be like,
yeah, I want a highlight of that story.
I was gonna, that's gonna be,
I'm getting a highlight on a bunny garden
and then I want to do highlights of that stream.
Yeah.
So yeah, I was so busy this month.
I think I'm anxious for the first day of the month
and not like, um, about like people donating.
It's more of just like, again,
I just want to make stuff worth it for you.
You know, I want you,
I want you guys to have a fun time.
My birthday.
It's like, I'm just like my parents,
my parents and they have people over.
They don't just like hang out and enjoy the company.
They like have to make sure everybody's having a great time,
like constantly and I'm just like that.
Even if it's an event to like celebrate me,
I just want to, you know,
I want to make it,
I want to make it about all of us.
Cause again, I wouldn't be able to do this stuff without you.
Yeah.
We didn't watch Megan.
We can do it in October.
That's a good idea.
Maybe for, um,
maybe I'll do two member streams a week
in, um,
October.
Maybe I'll do like one normal members
and then I'll do a watchable.
It's funny.
I asked my dad, um,
I'm like, you know,
well I didn't ask him.
I told him, I'm like,
you know, the alien movie was really good,
the Romulus.
And I'm like,
I really wish you came and saw it with me.
You would have liked it.
He's like, you know,
it's really funny.
And I'm like,
he's like,
when I was on the trip with your mom,
we, I literally just binge watched all the alien movie.
And I'm like,
I thought they scared you.
He's like,
they actually don't scare me as much as I thought they did.
And I'm like,
is this a thing again?
Like when mom was like gremlins is super scary,
but then she watched it when she was a kid.
So it was so much scary.
He's like, yeah.
So he's gonna,
um,
when it comes out on like on demand video or like,
I don't know,
like Google Netflix or whatever,
I'll go over and watch it.
And he says,
stretch clothes at least three out.
I am.
Um,
I, yeah,
I sent Strani all the info
because I talked about
some of you guys who aren't members,
you're missing out
because I talked with the members
and they helped me pick more Dorothon goals.
So yeah,
so you guys can get what you want.
And Strani is surprising me with the merch thing
that I don't know about.
She's like, can you guess?
And I'm like,
oh, in the hole?
And she's like, no.
And I'm like, damn it.
But yeah,
I'm getting birthday merch.
Just like,
just like Azura did.
I just don't know.
I'm getting,
um,
I don't know what I'm getting though.
I think I'm getting a mouse pad,
but I think there's something else,
but she won't tell me what it is.
Um,
so it's not,
sadly, no.
A cup?
No, I have to,
in order for,
one,
I would want a cup of all of us on it.
Um,
in order for us to get a cup,
we have to have a certain amount of,
um,
merch.
Slime Sheeby,
oh.
If Strani surprises me
with
Slime Sheeby merch,
even though I don't even have a Slime Sheeby design,
that would be pretty neat.
Madam have seen a para,
well,
what para do?
The para makes slimer?
What do you mean?
Say it.
Say it with your chest.
Hmm,
is there possibly,
is there possibly an event where,
if we use Code Sheeby,
we get free shipping?
So crazy that you say that.
Truly crazy.
Cause boy,
do I have the product for you.
If you use Code Sheeby
on gamer subs,
if you're feeling thirsty,
in the need of energy,
and you don't want stinky coffee,
you can use my Code Sheeby
to get free shipping worldwide.
And look,
I'm on the anime Girl Thigh.
Come,
you can get my lovely Milky Tail Thigh
for free shipping.
Yeah,
worldwide,
Mr. Worldwide.
You see.
Oops.
Funnub,
if you enjoyed,
please consider subscribing to my channel.
I know there was a lot of yak
the last 30 minutes
to an hour off the stream.
I apologize for the rod watchers
if that bothers you.
But you know,
somebody will probably do the,
what's it called,
the timestamps,
so it'll be a bolder tell.
You say hi rod watchers,
but they can't see you
cause they don't have the chat up.
Perik of maggots,
delicious.
You know,
I have some crickets I can eat.
I bought crickets
to consume
as a
donut thong thing.
How many people are subscribed to you?
A couple are the ones who aren't.
I have no idea.
Hi,
rod watchers.
Live chat says hi.
Adam Yaffe is my life force.
Adam is the...
Hi,
rod watchers.
Looking at like,
oh yeah,
we got a live chat replay.
Rod watchers use code chibi.
Okay,
I'm fading.
I think,
because I forgot to take my meds today.
Oh my God,
why am I feeling busy and loopy?
Oh, why didn't you take my medication?
What time is it?
I also woke up at like 7 a.m.
and I went to bed at 1.
All the sugar wearing off.
I didn't have sugar.
Actually,
I had pop rock.
Did he do me forgiving you?
Oh yeah,
he's forgiven me.
I squeezed his pouch.
Boomi's getting so chunky.
I'm like,
actually,
no,
but it's funny because like,
he's not like a lazy cat.
He's very active as you guys heard in the beginning.
It's just that he takes the other cat's food.
I'm like,
bro,
stop.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I know.
Hi.
I'm easy.
He's bulky.
Do you mean his crippled sister's food?
Sure.
And food from a 14-year-old woman.
That sounds weird in the context of...
She's a cat.
She's a 14-year-old cat.
Right now, it's 14.
I know.
And my brain is 14.
I'm looking at her though.
She looks,
she looks like at the youthful age of five.
Call her active.
They won't wear collars.
You will probably have a fit.
Being a force it needs your help.
14 years,
yeah,
it's like 80 cat ears.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know. She's very spry for her age.
I've had her for a very long, very, very long time
since I was only, I only believed in her.
Oh, that was the other two.
To 21? Damn, yes, I think cats can live a long time
However, she does have some health issues.
Like she has kidney disease.
So, um, but she's still, she's still going strong.
She's still, she's still kicking.
That was Boomi. Boomi was going crazy.
He decided that that was the time to have the Zoomies.
And then I was just like, oh wait, let me see if he needs these weapons before I start to train.
And then she drops, she pees for like two minutes straight
and then she drops in Miley's poop.
And I'm like, damn, Ma.
And I said, I have to give her another bath tomorrow.
She's stinking.
Okay, I'm going to raid Serenity.
I hope she's still streaming, but it's her birthday.
So she's probably still streaming.
So go say, funny birthday raid because, you know, she's a fellow bun.
It's also her birthday month.
So yeah, Serenity's birthday.
So go give her some love.
Now I'm going to go take my meds.
And then nap for a couple of hours.
And then beep, beep, and then actually go to sleep because I am tired.
Well, have a good rest of your night.
I care about you.
I hope you guys have a good rest of your day.
I hope you guys enjoy the stream.
Not too much.
Go finish something.
Go finish it.
Go finish that project.
Not that project.
The other one.
Okay.
Anyway, I said bonnichiwa this morning.
Siam bian bun, yeah?
I just sound like a terrible weeb.
Okay, bye.